-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Thank you for being here.
Let's get to some news.
Well, guys, today
President Biden met
with six state governors
to discuss ways that they can
get more Americans vaccinated.
Yep, they spent about 15 minutes
coming up with ideas
and three hours talking
about if Bennifer is back.
[ Laughter and oohs ]
That's right,
Biden needed more ideas
after Dr. Fauci refused to pose
for a shirtless calendar.
[ Laughter and applause ]
He said no.
It's crazy that this
is still a problem.
I mean, even COVID is thinking,
"I can't believe
I'm re-signing my lease.
[ Laughter ]
I didn't think I could get
the deposit back."
[ Laughter ]
I'm not sure what incentives
to get vaccinated are left.
I mean, so far, we tried food,
alcohol, drugs, gift cards,
sports tickets, money.
Pretty much just leaves sex,
doesn't it?
I mean, is that
where we're going?
[ Laughter ]
-Aah!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow!
-No, no, I'm not doing that.
No, no, no, no, I'm not.
[ The Roots playing funk ]
No, no, no, absolutely, no, no.
-Oh, dear.
-No, I really -- no.
Get vaccinated, everybody,
just please.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ Sultry voice ] Get the shot.
[ Laughter ]
-That's right,
the government is doing
all they can
to get people vaccinated.
Today, I read that the Biden
administration is teaming up
with McDonald's to help raise
vaccine awareness.
Yep, so get ready
for the all-new
McDerna.
It's going to be good.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Whoa, awesome!
-You know we're living
through historic times
when McDonald's is giving public
health advice, don't you think?
[ Laughter ]
Yep, McDonald's is even
putting up a billboard
in Times Square that says...
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Also, as long as McDonald's
is working to fight disease,
they might want to look
into whatever this thing was.
I have no idea.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Aww.
-Well, here in New York City,
it was just announced
that some subway stations
are offering COVID vaccines.
Yeah, first,
they sterilize your arm
with a $2 bottle of vodka
and a paper bag that was left
in the seat,
then, they hold the shot
near your arm
and a parkour dancer
kicks it in.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's going to be amazing.
This is actually cool --
they even got the MTA announcer
to list all of the side effects.
"Fever, headaches,
soreness, sweating."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Meanwhile, over in Italy,
a nurse accidentally
gave a woman
six doses of the Pfizer
vaccine in one shot.
[ Laughter ]
I think, in Italy,
they call that
family-style.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Six doses of the vaccine.
I'm 99% sure this is how every
Marvel movie starts, isn't it?
[ Laughter ]
"Save us, Captain Pfizer!"
At this point,
she's now protected
from COVID-19,
-20, -21, -22...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Well, just when we thought
we made it
through the worst
of the pandemic,
the next big threat
to public health has arrived.
-Starbucks is launching
the strawberry funnel cake
frappuccino.
[ Laughter ]
It has as many calories
as a double cheeseburger
at McDonald's.
It's a blend of strawberry purée
and whipped cream
with funnel cake pieces
and powdered sugar.
[ Laughter ]
-If you want one,
just walk in and say,
"Venti diabeté."
[ Laughter ]
You know someone's going
to be like,
"I'll take
a funnel cake frappuccino,
but can I get it
with skim milk?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Hushed ]
Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
Some entertainment news.
I saw that ABC just renewed
"Grey's Anatomy"
for an 18th season.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Oh.
-Even the cicadas
coming back are like,
"This show is still on?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Well, this is one
of our favorite
sporting events every year.
Russian President Vladimir Putin
plays in a hockey game
with professional players,
and, every year,
he does amazing.
-Really?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
In this game,
he scores eight goals.
-Eight goals?!
-Watch this. Yeah, watch.
-[ Russian accent ]
Vladimir Putin.
[ Speaking Russian ]
-Whoa!
Hey-oh!
[ Laughter ]
Going to -- What?
Oh!
Here he comes and -- yep!
♪♪
And there, yeah, fall down now.
Oops! Yeah, he slipped.
Eight goals, amazing.
Unbelievable.
One shot was blocked
and the goalie was later
"accidentally" run over
by a Zamboni.
[ Laughter and oohs ]
And, finally, I saw that
the cost of wood is increasing,
which is making toilet paper
more expensive.
Maybe that's why Dr. Fauci
was like,
"Well, let's not throw out
those face masks just yet."